uncertainty and logic and um we have a
very light program this afternoon so
will entertain us and then at three we
have a reception where we can all chat
um so we have all the attention for this
one go for it thank
you um so uh thank you all for being
here um I will
uh uh talk about The Credo models so so
this talk uh it's an attempt to convince
you that um um we may do well if we use
more than
probability um so let me start with um
uh 12 years
ago uh so this is an XKCD cartoon about
uh shot bots and well it was making joke
about that right and uh well nowadays we
are using or many of our students and
others are using
uh chat GPT with great success in in in
a number of tasks uh I'm not going to
claim in all tasks but um I would claim
at least that the joke is a bit
outdated
um and the reason well one of the
reasons for that is that we got more and
more data and and and more and more
computing power uh you don't have to try
to read this graph but it's just uh
showing how how faster we got in terms
of computing and also it's it's uh clear
that it got much cheaper uh to the point
that um about a year or two years ago um
I was asked to talk about deep fakes and
then I said I would try to do it I mean
I have no idea how to do this I had
never used any tools for that and then I
went online and I found some tools that
used uh generative ADV versets and you
could plug a video there and they you
know crushed the numbers and whatever I
had no idea what the thing was doing and
uh without uh much effort and within an
hour uh it's not amazing but I managed
to put the face of the Dan well still uh
prime minister on the face of the Dan
Health Minister when they were uh giving
one of the the press conferences it was
related to co and uh yes I got very
surprised at where we are with AI but
more recently and this is just U uh a
month ago or about so uh if you follow
uh some of the news Outlet so you're
going to see things like uh Game of
Thrones outo suing shot GPT you're going
to see Google being sued because of uh
uh directing motorists to a place that
there is no bridge for more than I don't
know eight years or 10 years some
something like that uh so things uh have
changed in in in AI uh there are many
consequences of that uh so the the
research has grown very fast with with
impa in society many applications many
people using
this uh and many people claiming that uh
there is Need for regulation of AI and
and the research in AI certification and
um uh investment uh you're going to see
here joke of uh um AI uh trying to uh
help itself
um I will go further so this is uh uh
now a bit more than a month ago uh if
you look on BBC News then you would see
uh
um a news article with a few comments
inside and I will quickly read the
comments uh Congress should engage with
AI to support Innovation safeguards
that's was zuken BG from meta and then I
think if this technology goes wrong it
can go quite wrong we want to be vocal
about that that's Alman from open AI the
shot GPT we want to work with the
government to prevent that from
happening and uh I think there should be
a regulatory B established it for overse
AI to make sure that it does not present
a danger to the public that is Musk from
SpaceX X Tesla and so and he continues
better that the standard is set by
American companies that can work with
government to shape this models on
important
issues um I'm not going to dive into
discussing this but um I think that uh
and well I I'm I'm a a person in
University and I think we should be
involved on this and one way of being
involved is maybe to try to make steps
on AI and and models uh that give us
more uh Trust on on what is going on so
I brought a few examples for us um I
hope that uh the examples clarify a few
points uh in my selling of uh this
something more than probability thing
that will become clear later so let's
say you have a patient Mr siik that
either has an autoimmune disease or an
infection and without treatment he will
likely die very soon uh if you don't
know the treatment for one of these
diseases typically kill you if you have
the other and vice
versa um and assume the diseases are
equally likely U it's a is a fake
example um let's say that after studying
this case in private the doctor
imprecise uh tells she does not know
whether it's a or b which one of the two
diseases while dror precise tells it a
so which doctor you would prefer if you
were Mr
siik um I would not ask you to answer
the questions because I'm getting every
time disappointed when I use this
example and I don't want to get
disappointed with you um I would tell my
answer and my answer would be uh
probably I would be more impressed by Dr
precise because it told uh told me
something the other just said I don't
know but let's now switch to looking
inside let's in this hypothetical
example think the following doctor imp
prze concluded that she doesn't know by
studying the data carefully analyzing
everything and then she said I cannot
get to a conclusion and let's say Dr
precise gave an answer a after flipping
a
coin uh now I'm very sure about which
one I prefer uh I prefer the doctor
inise even if I still do not know which
one is is my disease but uh I have this
knowledge so I can uh work uh further on
it trying to find more advice and so
on um let me go for another example uh
about knowing when we don't know so
let's say that we have a typical uh task
of classifying digits so you're giving
images and you have to guess what's the
number and the image um what is best so
it's best an approach an AI approach
that always predicts the digit uh and
gives you an accuracy of let's say 90%
or is better an approach that
uh predicts an image uh a digit uh with
accuracy
99.9 but sometimes it says I don't
know obviously assuming that this I
don't know does not happens too often
because otherwise then you you don't
have so much information or even another
approach which uh sometimes predicts as
multiple digits so it says to you it's a
six or an eight but nothing else with an
accuracy of
99.99%
uh and there is no I don't think there's
a correct answer here but it really
depends on the task that you have and
the type of risk that you you are
dealing
with let's go one example further here
uh let's say that BBC spay us to uh
discover the popularity of his standards
of long running soap opular and we
decide to call 10 random valid phone
numbers and four people answered the
phone and said they like standard one
answered the phone and said they do do
not like standards and five did not
answer the phone so a typical AI
approach uh you got five answers 80%
like standards is is that okay to just
report that to to BBC as as the
conclusion um let's just have a quick
thought about here right so there
there's something missing that we didn't
use so standards is I think more popular
among older maybe you may argue that's
not the case but uh it seems this to be
the case and young people typically do
not does not answer the phone so I think
that would already maybe change our
impression and what how we have to deal
with those five cases that did not
answer the pH so I think that we can do
a few things to improve AI so there are
many desirable properties uh and those
examples they touch on some of these
points in
interpretability uh robustness uh
including to missing information uh the
explainability of what you're doing
privacy or awareness and fairness uh but
usually this cost something and uh uh
and my question is if we're willing to
pay this price for
something so this is my justification
that uh well U we should think very well
about improving AI in the best possible
way and I will talk about the
probabilistic uh view of this so um
there are at least three different
levels uh of knowledge that we could
encode um the first here well let's
first take this example as being a
football match between Italy and and and
Sweden uh and we are interested in the
outcome for Italy which can be a win a
draw or a loss so let's say that uh uh
we know that Buon that is Italy
goalkeeper is unbeatable and Sweden
always gets at least a goal against them
so in this case we are certain Italy
wins so we can represent this with a
probability of wing equal to one and
zero for the other two to possible
outcomes but you may be a bit more
uncertain you may say Wing is twice so
two times more probable than a draw and
this is three times more probable than a
loss and you can again represent this
with a probability Mass function 6.3.1
in this case and you can go even a step
further which is the step further well
you could just say that Wing is more
probable than a draw and this is more
probable than a loss so you're not
really specifying one probability
but you're specifying constraints and
probabilities so you could write down
these as constraints as we have here um
I will argue that this in Precision is
quite useful but before I go there I
will show a bit of circuit because I
will enhance that Circle circuit with
you towards that type of imprecision so
let's open this parenthesis so that I
can talk about first the probabilistic
case but the precise probabilistic case
so uh uh folks have been working on uh
uh what was called it some product
networks 12 years ago and you may hear
this as probabilistic circuits here um
there is a bit of confusion on
terminology but U uh I will use here
some product networks to make it clear
uh the restrictions I'm using on it so
in this case we have a model that is
something between the neuron one side
which have circuits and the Bia networks
on the other side that are graphs that
you can interpret as with a mark of
condition the circuits are somehow in
between and they have present complex
mixtures of distributions one
distribution multivariate in this
example here you have a distribution
over two buan variables A and B the
circuit is a graph we have different
types of nodes so we have here indicator
uh functions I'm only use binary uh
random variables here to make the the
exposition simpler but it's not a
limitation uh you have weighted sums so
the sum no notes are weighted sums of
the children of them in this dog in this
directly cly graph and you have product
nodes which are product uh of the
children and we use a few extra
constraints in this uh some product
networks so the product nodes multiply
variables that are a partition of the uh
the variables that it had in that case
so that's why you see X and Y in one
side and z and W on the other side so it
has to be a partition and the Su nodes
are over the same variables that's why
you see p of XY and then you see p of XY
in the in the children and that is what
you also see in the graph here uh one
greater advantage of this type of
circuit is that yeah it's representing a
joint distribution for the variables in
this case A and B and you can compute
marginals and conditions very
efficiently so if you want to do
inference in this example here you want
to compute the P of a equal to true all
you have to do is to put zero on what is
against what you want to to compute so
we put a zero on the leaf that has not a
they put a one on the rest and you
propagate Computing products and
weighted sums and you get the marginal
probability of way there on
top so you can do marginal probabilities
very efficient you can do condition very
efficient you can uh then work with this
distribution to do uh decision making
classification and and and model your
domain um there is yes connection of
this to the trees the C they have seen
before
uh uh the they are the same as uh many
other models I mean there are semantic
difference in some cases uh some others
a bit syntactic difference uh we can
discuss more on on these details because
it depends on the assumptions you use
inside the the the
structure we could we could talk a bit
more about but yeah it's they are very
similar uh I hear there is another
example actually they are very similar
to decision threes so if you take a
decision three that you see on the left
you can easily write it as as a
probabilistic circuit uh what you see in
the in the right uh in the picture here
and uh well this connection is very nice
because uh automatically you get a
generative model out of decision three
or or or a random forest and you can use
this as your machine learn model so in
the case of these generative random
forests uh since rof Forest are a
state-of-the-art for tabular data uh
this translation keeps us with the same
results the same state-of-the-art uh
results for tabular data uh but you get
tractable marginals so you manage now to
work with missing data so you can
compute probability of uh uh your class
giving evidence that does not need to be
complete uh you can use the probability
of your uh observation for instance to
try to do outlar detection
uh you can use uh smoo values on Leaf
nodes to make your the the boundaries of
your decision smoother and not as just
as a decision Tre which are sharp uh
partition of your uh space you can do
robustness and we are going to do a bit
of that in sensitivity analysis so
interpreting this random Forest as
circuits give you a few benefits you
still have one probability distribution
but you can do a few cool things with
that so you can use P of x to try to
know when you don't know so if you look
there to the left you are going to see
the cases uh that have a low p ofx and
in red when you got right or wrong when
you try to classify those images uh on
top is the amist and the bottom is the
fashion amist and if you look to the
right side you're going to see the case
where P of X was high so you have a very
high probability of the observation and
in those case you you see lots of green
right but also you do you do see not so
much variation on those uh but it's a
benefit so I the benefit of having P ofx
but you can use to try to understand if
you're doing a good job or not a measure
of quality of your classification
results uh you could use for alar
detection so it's also a common data set
on wine on the left you're going to see
the data trained with white wine and
then you see the P ofx for both white
and red wine and you see that there is a
better Separation on the bottom where
we're looking the P of X instead of
looking to the marginal probability of
the class given X which is all you can
do if you don't have the P of X in in a
generative model and the same on the
other side but inverting train it with
red wine and then you see how they split
red and and white
wine uh but P of X has limitations too
so imagine a case that you have a um
badly written fives and six but you have
many of them so you have many fives many
six so it could be that P of X for those
are are quite high but is still there is
uh lots of uncertainty between five and
six so we could try to do a step forward
here Beyond P of X and uh I will argue
for this sets of probability
distribution so this is a critos set the
definition of cros set first in our
example there we had determinism that
was one probability was a one for one of
the outcomes and zero for all the
others we can use single probabilities
so each one of the blue points is one
probability distribution one is uh uh
Point 4.6 the other is
7.3 or you can use as your model to
represent your knowledge a set in this
case an interval between those points so
the blue line here so the credos sets
are basically a a a GE metric uh uh
entity in high dimension a polytop uh we
usually assume them to be convex and
they give us uh more power in
representing because well a point is
also critos set but you can use a set
instead of using a single point to
represent your knowledge so you start
with one point it's it's a singletone
but it is a cros set but you could use
any kind of polytope you want there and
one of the key advant for instance is to
model ignorance so if you just take a
uniform distribution usually this means
that you like all the outcomes equally
it doesn't mean that uh you don't know
anything so you could better use your
whole Simplex so all the probability
distributions that exist as your initial
information as your state of knowledge
at that point so it gives you more
flexibility there and you can also then
uh extend this by putting expert
knowledge such that the this probability
is greater of this outcome is greater
the probability of the other outcome as
we did for the the example of Italy
versus Sweden and you can go beyond
making lots of rules which typically
help you with experts to represent your
knowledge by using intervals instead of
using uh just single uh probability
values with these models you can go
beyond using a single variable and use
multiple variables so in this example
here there are two binary variables
obviously the domain of the the the
problem gets higher so the dimension is
higher this credle set becomes a more
complicated polytop in higher uh
Dimension but all the rules that we are
going to use they they work there too so
we can do a mapping between a
probability and a set of probabilities
so before we go to that I have to
mention there are things to pay for when
you go to set sets of distribution so
when you have one probably distribution
we typically define independence of two
variables as the pro marginal
probabilities of those variables can be
multiplied so P of X and Y can be uh
factorize as P of x times P of i
y uh if you have sets then you have
different types of
definitions uh I can quickly think about
two of them to consider and this is
something you have to have in mind when
you working with sets so one way would
be uh call it a strong way uh of
defining inde dependence is to Define
that you have stochastic Independence in
each one of the extremes of your set so
the borders of your set the corners of
your set the extreme points satisfy the
pointwise probability Independence
concept but there is another call
epistemic irrelevance where actually you
say that your set does not change when
you observe something it's a set concept
so it's like you have information about
X as a set and then you observe Y and
the set Remains the Same set for X this
is way more complicated to deal with and
I will not go there but I wanted to
alert you we pay something when you want
a model that is more
expressive so I'm going to work with the
strong Independence uh through now one
to show you a few uh use cases of it and
with strong Independence yes there also
stronger Independence where everything
in the set has that's not compx anymore
I guess yes you have convex issues uh
and uh often what you can work around is
by convexifying the sets when you do
operations on it uh but yes there are
other Concepts uh we can also talk more
about that uh every concept you use you
may end up inducing a different model
with that
I will try to uh stick to let's say the
one that is closest to sensitivity
analysis in precise models because
that's what I'm going to show as a use
case uh in the next slides but you have
a you have a good point is called it
complete Independence and well you can
hear a few other different uh uh
definitions of Independence so when you
go yes about the intuition the intuition
about using a set of probabilities is
you want to say that you don't know
which one is the right one is that the
intuition that's one of the possible
interpretations of it um it it could be
interpreted as um I don't have a single
one so it's not that I don't know which
one is the correct one I will say that
the world is imprecise so the correct
thing is a set that would be a little
bit different interpretation I will use
in this presentation your uh exactly
explanation I will assume there is a
correct one and I will say that my set
is my lack of knowledge of which one is
but it's one of those so
indeed uh with this concept which is the
simplest call it the the strong version
simplest in terms of explaining to you
uh where each point extreme Point has to
satisfy what a probability distribution
would satisfy in the precise case we can
do all the uh typical operations of
probability as we would applying it to
each point in the set so that's all that
this SL is telling us so if you want now
to manipulate sets just repeat your
process as you would do in one
probability with all the extremes of
that and keep convexifying if needed uh
I I I ask you if you are questioning
what what this conversific is generating
uh and the problems let's discuss this
later okay but it's it's really not a
big deal as um many of the things that
we do are actually linear in this high
dimension spaces so the solution will be
in extreme point so it does not create
really big
problems so the basic operations is
repeat the same for each one of the
points but you have you may have many
points on this big polytop so we do have
better ways of computing but I'm not
going to go there on how to compute with
this though you can already see that is
more complicated than working with a
single one obviously you have many of
them so not necessarily you you're going
to get algorithms with the same kind of
speed that you would if you have a s
one uh typical then extension and I
would mention in two one is extending
Bion networks to The Credo case so if
you are aware of ban networks so this
you have this do directly CLI graph with
a mark of condition so every variable is
independent of the non descendants given
the parents which uh induces a
factorization or you can look this the
other way around you can come from the
factorization uh and and and induce your
definition but it is a very nice uh
representation and very interpretable
representation typically what you put
associate to the nodes is a a
conditional distribution for the node
the varable associate the node given the
parents in the crle case what we do is
that we associate a set for the node
given the parents so it's a natural
extension of a Basia Network towards
sets but now you have all the sets in
each one of the nodes so you can see
that computations will be way more
complicated because if you want to do uh
variable elimination you have to
consider all the possible extreme points
and keep multiplying working with all of
those so there are there are quite
efficient algorithms not tractable don't
get me wrong when I say efficient they
are pretty slow uh but we can solve many
interesting uh problems and there are
cases where this is even as fast as the
precise uh so this is an example with
numbers of very well-known little bean
Network and you have intervals defining
the conditional Mass functions instead
of numbers for each one of the mass
functions and this has been using um I
will not talk much about but you can ask
Alexandre about because well he his his
application so the Swiss Air Force seems
to be very happy with the idea of not
taking decisions
sometime uh but I will leave I I will
leave you with that uh but there are
really cases where having sets of
distributions is appreciated more than
having a single
one uh to work with those though we have
a uh a bit more of a a discussion here
on how we are going to get to be able to
do classification with this because if
you have sets of probabilities it could
be that some of them tell you that this
is a nine if you do the operations with
one of the extreme points and another
one tells this that this is a three so
what you do with that well a typical
thing or the simplest one is to compute
bounce for in this example the
probability of wing and the blue
represent the bounce so the maximum and
the minimum probability of wing and you
do the same for uh draw and the same for
loss and if the intervals do not overlap
then you can discard those that are
under because they are not the best you
can do better than that and you can
compare not the intervals on the
outcomes but the results for each one of
the PS that you have and if for every P
one of them is better than the other you
can also discard that option and keep
the one that always beats the
other and this is what here it's called
Uh uh the maximality uh criteria so
there are a few different decision
criteria when you work with sets because
it's the same as having the opinion of
multiple people and you have to have a
decision-making procedure on how to deal
with the opinion of all this people
which in this case is the probability
distributions that are represented by
taking the extreme points of the credle
sech and the second model that I'm going
to mention to you is the credle version
of that sun product networ the credle
version of the probabilistic circuit and
naturally what we do is instead of
putting weights on the sum nodes we put
sets of Weights in the sum nodes so it's
a quite natural extension just as in the
case of The Credo beijan Network that
instead of local condition distrib dists
we put sets of local condition
distributions here for the weights I we
put sets of Weights in this example for
for for the values of I cannot reach for
the values of U X4 for for instance you
have a set there with an an interval
that goes from point 54 to
64 uh and so on so in this case you just
build it with the intervals you would
like I will build them with a certain
way in a moment
uh I would
take uh probabilistic circuit learn it
in the way that you like the most so
give me a probabilistic circuit
representing a probability distribution
and now I'm going to take every one of
the weights that you have there and I
will perturb them a little bit so this
is what this is trying to represent in
the picture so it's called Epson
contamination you take your precise
distribution and build an interval
around it and this builds to you a
credle version of probabilistic circuit
but which interval how you define this
yes so I will call Epsilon
robustness the maximum Epsilon that you
keep increasing this set until the point
that doesn't matter which point you take
inside your decision is the same so if
you start that in the middle and you're
saying this is a nine now I start
growing the intervals everywhere up to
the point that doesn't matter how I
choose be they all say it's a nine but
there is a moment that's one of them you
say I think it's a three it stop exactly
at that moment okay and that is what I'm
going to call the absolum as absolum
robustness if you can grow this a lot
means that even if the parameters of
your model would be perturbed quite a
lot you would still get the same answer
this is done per instance so you give me
an X and you asking me a why what do I
do I take your circuit I guess the Y
using the
circuit and then I start making that
circuit in precise Credo growing until
the Y is still the same up to that last
point when y changes depending on the
the extreme point you choose I
stop okay so now we know what the
Epsilon
is then uh this graph will show you uh
reasonably
monotone uh set of functions one for
each data set and on the X you are going
to see the amount of Epsilon robustness
and on the Y you're going to see the
accuracy of the model for a certain
subset of your data based on the Epsilon
robustness I will not try to go to the
details of the graph but the important
thing here is that as you are more
robust you also have higher accuracy and
you can compute absolent robustness
without knowing the answer so you can
tell if you're doing a good job or not
before really checking if what you
guessed is correct how is this different
of P of X well it's
different uh P of X is a measure of the
the how many how many things you saw
close to that point uh this is a measure
of how much you can perturb your model
sensitivity analysis if you will uh
until your decision changes so it's a
more of a diversal way of looking to to
to to the task
so in this graph you're going to see on
the left
side uh the uh results with the highest
and lowest absolent robustness the the
far left is the lowest and then the the
next one is the highest set of highest
absolent robustness and on the Block on
the the right side you're going to see
the P of X that we had seen before okay
I just copied here so if you take a look
there is more variability so they are
different the Epsilon robustness when it
is right is not like lots of ones like
you see on the P of X and I'm not going
to claim which one is better here uh I
think that goes maybe beyond the amount
of time I have but I'm going to claim
that this absolent robustness is uh a
pretty interesting way of analyzing uh
if the thing that you are guessing when
you do classification would change if
you had learned the model with a slight
variation a slight change on your model
so this is uh uh they use for robust
classification which at some point got
quite interesting results is it obvious
that you can even compute this Epsilon
because there's so many points yes
um it's uh not obvious that you can
compute that for any type of model but
for The Credo probabilistic circuits you
can do that in uh linear time for a
given absolum and you can do by B
section to find your
Epsilon so
exp uh well you actually pick an Epsilon
this induces a credle set you can
compute in linear time if you have a
single answer or not I cannot explain
how that quickly but basically you can
propagate Maxes and means because that's
what matters you can compute efficiently
the result of expectation of functions
even with negative uh values so you do
that computation and you can say there
is more than an answer here or all the
P's agree you can do that in linear time
and then the Epsilon you can you have to
have fix it for that to be in linear
time or you have to propagation a
function of Epsilon but the solution to
that is to do bisection on the abson
later on which gives you a Precision
very quickly so if you run that uh you
know five times you already have a quite
good idea where the absolum is but we
can discuss later on uh how I do this
that efficiently but it is uh same
complexity as the precise uh probalistic
circuit this
computation so uh every time you
propagate when you do products uh you
just if you want Maxes of Maxes you do
Maxes and uh if you do sums you just
solve a very small continuous gapsa
problem if you have intervals or if you
want more General it's a linear
programming is a small linear
programming problem that is there in the
more General case but if you have
intervals is a very tiny continuous s up
problem so the algorithm is really
really fast to to run this as fast as
the the PCS indeed this is a very a key
benefit of of that so we can compute
this zaps on quite
quickly um this is actually quite old
but I wanted to to to show um uh because
it gives us a quite nice intuition on uh
what the model is discovering by
sensitivity analysis so if you look to
the first row there those are people
with are forcing a surprise face and if
you look to that graph surprise is the
easiest so on the X there you have the
Epsilon uh robustness and it's way more
robust for surprise when you compare
that to hunger and disgust which are the
two L lines and arguably it's quite hard
to to to discover the difference between
the two last lines here but the one that
on top is very clearly different
so this was a nice thing and that that
we got uh with the Epsilon
robustness so this was my attempt to
sell you uh sets of probability
distributions there is lots of ongoing
research on this uh there is a quite
strong relation with uh uh causal
inferences that I believe you're going
to hear about in a few days uh we are
doing credos circuits for portolio
optimization uh and and a couple of
other uh topics in in in in finance
we're doing crto
clustering uh very soon we're going to
have some interesting results related to
the uh steps that you have inside a a
neuron Network as as kedo clustering uh
we are trying to use this to combine
this probabilistic logic and deep models
using kedos sets and this is the topic
that I'm going to um uh spend my last
slide on is the third bullet here uh to
tell you why this is why this is quite
interesting but I don't have the final
result here so I would call this
unpublished work and invitation to join
um if you if you think about uh uh
probabilistic propositional logic let's
go simple on that say you tell me the
probability of A or B it's equal to 0.3
uh so you tell me a probability uh of a
probabilistic logic
formula uh we can easily encode this in
a in a type of Basia network with with
putting evidence
there we could do this forcing Bond and
three with so forcing that network not
to be too
dense and we could do structureal
learning with those
variables this can be compiled into a
probabilistic circuit to make it
computation
uh quite
efficient uh there are some five steps I
jumped here already you actually have to
invert uh some nodes to be able to put
this constraint there there are few
intricacies but the the overall idea
here is that you get a circuit and then
you can train this so one of the nice
things of circuit also you're training
the parameters directly on the circuit
so just as parameters of a neuron
networks are trained and this usually
gives you uh a boost on quality of uh uh
your your
model and by doing a procedure like that
you get sort of a a neuros symbolic AI
Direction uh we are trying this via
Transformations we are trying currently
this directly on circuits and we can
discuss a few different ways of trying
to put them together I'm not going to go
to all the details but I wanted to
emphasize why the crto version is so
essential actually without the credle
version we cannot do this steps and the
reason why it's so essential the crle
version is that if you tell me that the
probability of a being true or B is true
is equal to a certain number here call
it W uh A or
B if you tell me that you are actually
not telling me anything about the
marginals you are just telling me
something about this
or and with the Credo version I can take
a circuit and I can put that weight
there for the A or
B without having to specify the weights
for each one of the three atoms that
satisfy that the configurations that
satisfy that I can leave that as a crle
set I can leave that unspecified as a
set and I can do inferences later on so
that's the key or why The Credo version
can help us so much on putting
probabilistic uh propositional logic
into this uh deep
models uh and then we can discuss
further if you are very interested on
the topic uh I think there is lots going
on at the the moment on trying to to to
to mix those two so this is my talk um I
think I'm on time so the the joke about
being late is a bit wrong but thank
you
questions so I have a question um so if
I remember correctly from a very long
time ago when people started doing
protic logic so you know nilson Helper
and buckus they considered probability
statements of the one on your previous
slide right they said the probability of
certain events is some number and then
they were all studying you know the
satisfiability of these constraint does
is the credle set empty or not right and
so have you studied these connections
between kind of the you know 40 35 year
old protic logic literature and credle
sets because I think it's very related
yeah it is H thank thanks of the
question yeah it's it's indeed very
related um uh just checking if the the
crle set is going to be empty or not in
general it's going to be a hard task uh
but the circuits come to save us in that
so I think that the the there are few
combinations of things that we didn't
have at that point one of them is this
probabilistic circuit where you can do
inferences efficiently and for instance
queries on the circuit like is this
empty or not uh you can do efficiently
so if you have a beion network then you
have the problem of what is the
complexity that of the the inferences
you're going to run on this including
the complexity of the inference uh is
this empty or not the circuits come to
save us on that side so I would say uh
we have more uh material now to work
than we had at that time the second
point and maybe I don't want to go too
philosophical on that but U there is
quite a big difference if we we
say um what's the probability of uh of
this uh uh variable given a certain uh
logic formula and what's the probability
of this uh
variable given that the probability of
this logic formula is one even even
those two things are uh huge different
results and I think that this is another
thing that we couldn't process before so
uh in the first case if you do that you
are actually updating when you update
you end up not answering the same as you
would uh without updating and the second
you're not doing updating you're just
putting a constraint inside and I think
30 40 years we we didn't have a
computational power to to handle those
things but many of the ideas are the
same as there I would say in some sense
we are bringing back some of those ideas
with tools that we have now
that's how I would interpret that yeah
yeah I think it's worth investigating
that connection because at the time it
was really just a logic right like you
made statements in a logic about the
probability of certain events and
they're conditional and then it was
really the set problem in the sense of
does there exists such a distribution
that has these properties and then when
it's when is it decidable what is the
complexity and so on yes All Those
Questions are still the same right the
difference is to be able to use like
circuits to well basically we are
restricting another way of telling it
the same is that we are restricting the
the the models that we work with with
models that are efficient to do the
computation because obviously if we
don't then the thing is hard there's
nothing to do about yeah you just
answered the question that I wanted to
ask because there is a caveat when we
say oh circuits are very efficient
they're efficient because you force them
to be small so uh if you start from an
arbitrary basing Network and convert it
to to a circuit if it's I mean sometimes
it will be small and then sometimes it
will not be small it will be still
exponential so I think that's that's an
important point but we should remember
it yeah thank you for for for the
comment indeed and one of the one of the
the the the reasons to to try to work
with circuits directly or at least one
of of the the justifications was to say
I fix the size of the model so in
whatever I want in terms of complexity
and then it's fast because I fixed the
size right which is something we cannot
do with compilation unless we fix some
characteristics of the basion network to
start with like we do the learning with
a bounded uh uh three wave or some other
characteristic that would make the
translation efficient so indeed thanks
all right if there's no further
questions actually we still have 10
minutes before the reception start and
as you may have noticed in the schedule
there's some time for discussion the
next few days where hopefully we can do
some whiteboarding and and solve some
open problems and so Casio was uh eager
to share with us an open problem about
the complexity of marginal map on three-
shaped graphical models which uh is a
much simpler problem than anything
involving credle sets so this might be
something you can solve here this
week okay uh so let me change the Hat um
I don't care about CTO sets anymore um
and I will talk to about a very simple
problem that uh maybe you do have the
solution and I don't but I do not know
so if you do then please tell me um and
if you do not have the solution but you
are interested I'm very happy to talk
about uh because I started looking to
the problem way too long ago uh that is
uh 20 plus years and and I still do not
know the solution of this one and it's
too simple as a problem so I'm hoping
you do have the solution so the example
is here so let's say you have a
collection of BU and
variables and you have a collection of
functions of two bullan variables to no
negative integers in this case here say
faab fa a c c d and so on those are
bullan variables okay so you can look to
each one of those functions as just a
mapping returning you four numbers for
each one of the four uh configurations
of those two
okay those are uh the functions there is
a restriction here is that the
underlying graph has no cycle so if you
write down an edge every time you have a
function between two of those bulling
functions you draw the graph no
Cycles
okay now the question is I want to
choose the values of the leaf
nodes to maximize the product of those
functions so in this example I want to
choose the values of of b e and
f to maximize the product of all the
functions that are defined here in the
domain that's it that's my problem over
acing over AC oh I I I missed I missed
the the the the summing the slide sorry
I did the slide a few minutes ago I'm
summing over the others yes yes so I I
would not dare to change this slide now
but I have
pen uh so of course
so I'm summing over the variables that
are not in Orange here and that is the
function that is
there I think it was proved to
be um it is um
so uh I do have a table
somewhere
um so uh there are a few different
configurations there but basically if
you go Beyond Boolean or if you make
this the graph more complex then you get
a different kind of beast on your zoo uh
most of them are NP complete but
sometimes it goes to NP with a PP Oracle
if you have a general Basia network uh
it gets to weird configurations
depending on the type of sum you put
here but I want to concentrate on the
simplest of all of those which is the
case
where they are all booing and there is
no cycle here
so this case I do not know the answer if
you give me the option of using one
ternary variable I can show it's it's NP
hard but if you give me all Boolean ones
I do not know if you give me the
opportunity to to if you say that you
are doing the minimization instead of
maximization of this I also can show you
his NP hard but the maximization I
can't uh or or maybe you I I don't know
about but I was not able to make this
proof and then I went to code because I
said if I don't know how to do it I code
so uh I wrote a quite efficient
algorithm to solve this it's based on
keeping a par dominance for when you
propagate these values and then I I I've
run experiments with different type of
uh uh structures in the graph and I did
both for the minimum and for the
maximum max value is the is a range for
the output of the function
uh nodes is the number of nodes they are
all binary and if you take a look on
this table for the minimization version
uh the top there is with a particular
structure but random
parameters the problem seems to get
harder as I increase the number of nodes
um for the maximization it it didn't if
I encode the partition problem into the
minimization version because I can prove
is NP hard by a uh uh reduction from
partition and um it obviously grows I'm
not surprised by that
um I cannot do the same because I don't
have a uh obviously I don't have a
reduction to the other otherwise I would
tell you zp hard but if you take uh
random structures with random parameters
the minimization again starts to grow as
you grow the number of nodes while the
maximization
doesn't so there is some sort of lack of
SYM symmetry on the Max and the me and
it's a very very particular case of this
so Reena is completely right this is
closed for almost every case uh I would
even dare to say I'm not sure if anybody
cares about this case uh but I don't
know the answer so
um you you show that the map is already
hard for naive P right yes can we just
like simulate na Bas but just having
like but I I need more than binary I
need more than binary in that proof but
you need aary variable right yes two
binaries you Inc theary and you just
reject the last value then is not a it's
not a threee anymore to do that because
you have to connect those two to
everything else can I can't I emulate
like exponential many states where just
like taking no because it's a three but
you just need two noes right and they're
already connected yeah but you have to
connect the others to the two nodes
don't solve it already this is for
tomorrow right tomorrow at 3:30 we solve
this problem yeah but I I like the
discussion anyway I think it's a simple
enough problem and maybe you do have a
solution and I I would be very happy to
hear about I I do not
know okay so uh thanks again CIO and uh